the more you look at their pizza the
more you're like wait from producing
original drama series to his hilarious
impressions I'm just on my way to I
don't know going somewhere in my big
expensive car and even his apology
videos I'm gonna start by saying I am
NOT a pedophile YouTube star Shane
Dawson is internet royalty Dawson began
his YouTube career in 2007 when the idea
of becoming famous on YouTube was
unheard of and he's been making waves
ever since Shane I'm a comedian I'm a
writer I'm a director now we're breaking
down seven times Shane broke the
Internet this is a really hard to do for
me to make and I'm really scared I am
bisexual
Shane quickly became a voice for the
LGBTQ community after posting his coming
out video love do you wanna love life is
short nobody's gonna hate you for it
Shane and Geoffrey star caused an
internet frenzy after launching their
highly anticipated conspiracy makeup
collab oh my god okay you guys don't
kill me in shame but you guys broke the
whole entire website
the pair gave live updates on social
media during the launch sharing that
their line sold out in minutes the
conspiracy palette Shane we have to just
say it the conspiracy palette is sold
out worldwide
then there was the documentary the truth
about tannic on not only was tarancón
a failure but it was a safety hazard his
three-part youtube series focus on the
counter convention to VidCon created by
youtuber Tana mojo was a mess Tana
wasn't taking accountability she wasn't
returning anybody's phone calls her
taxes everything about this was Tana is
gonna go and pretend that she cares
about people right now by giving water
so the people are gonna get in because
this whole event is canceled for the day
people have labeled it the fire festival
of social media influence or meetups
with no bathrooms no water no the truth
about tannic on 1 the 2018 Streamy Award
for Best Documentary here is the most
inspiring amazing reinventing creator on
this platform I love you dad I love you
Shane congratulations this other
documentary the mind of Jake Paul
shocked his fans when I tweeted that I
would be interested in doing it the
backlash I thought was crazy no no no no
no I am NOT watching Jake Paul crazier
than anything I've ever gotten with
millions of views the series took
Shane's audience into Jake's world but
through Shane's one-of-a-kind POV this
is gonna be a nightmare
but with all the highs come the lows I
cannot believe that I am having to make
this video I cannot believe that this is
happening the vlogger issued an apology
video for jokes he made about pedophilia
here's my statement I'm a pedophile it's
disgusting that people are saying I'm
pedophile because if some ask jokes from
six years ago on a podcast
Shane's apology video became one of
YouTube's top trending videos at the
time with over seven million views
before his dogs Shane went in depth with
his investigating conspiracies with
Shane Dawson series where his chucky
cheese pizza theory left everyone shook
there is a theory that if somebody at
Chuck E Cheese doesn't finish their old
pizza and there's like a few pieces left
the employee will take that to the back
take those pieces off the tray and form
a new pizza with all the other leftovers
the video currently has over 37 million
views it shows Shane ordering pizza at
Chuck E Cheese testing now his theory
but it's not just his videos that leave
the internet shook it his relationship
does to like when he proposed some
longtime boyfriend Rylan Adams he stood
there crying for a long time than people
literally it was so long that your
family just having left their engagement
post on Instagram it has gained over
five million likes Wow
[Music]